what kind of person do you think
gottlieb was like like after you know
aside from all like the gruesome
acts that he committed torturing people
and essentially murdering
innocent people for these experiments
what kind of a guy was he outside of
work
that's another thing that makes sydney
godley so interesting
so he was the most gentle-hearted
torturer
you could ever imagine sydney godley who
carried out these
horrifically grotesque experiments
and just left a trail of blood and
devastation behind him
was a sweetheart he was like a
proto-hippie
he lived unlike any civil servant in
washington in the 1950s i'm sure
he lived in a a cabin in the woods out
in virginia it had no running water
uh he got up before dawn to milk his
goats
he meditated he studied buddhism he
wrote
poetry uh he grew his own vegetables
uh and brought homemade bread into uh
eat for lunch at the cia
so somehow he was able to reconcile
these two sides of his personality
while writing that book poisoner in
chief i tried to
imagine how he did that he never spoke
or wrote about his own feelings
or about his own work but i would ask
myself how
how does a person who's so unorthodox
and so humanistic justify
uh carrying out such bloody deeds
and and i'm just speculating now but
maybe this is one thing he might have
told himself he might have said
i'm a very unorthodox person
i'm not like the mainstream guy the way
i live
and i'm able to do this because i live
in a free country
we are now facing an enemy that wants to
make it impossible forever
for anybody ever to live like i do
everyone's going to have to be in a
automaton
and fit into the pro-christian soviet
bet that's what we were being told in
those days
uh and in order to prevent that from
happening
in order to assure that meaningful life
will be possible in the future and that
everything that's creative and beautiful
will be able to survive
i have to do these things it shows you
how you really can
lose sight of the
devastation you're causing by creating
in your mind
an image of something that you use to
justify it
how did he utilize lsd
and and what sort of experiments
was he involved with using lsd on
on his prisoners or his subjects or
whatever
and how is that how is the lsd part of
this significant
godly was fascinated by lsd
it had only recently been discovered
when he came to the cia
and the fact that it could have such
potent effects in such small
quantities and it was colorless and
odorless uh made him think that this
might be the key to mind control
he was so fixated on lsd that in 1953
sydney godley persuaded the cia to buy
the entire world supply of lsd
uh and and the cia did that they bought
it from sandoz
in switzerland which was the sole
producer
so what did godly then do with that lsd
well part of it he used in horrifically
grotesque
experiments that were highly coercive
and he wanted to see if lsd could be
used to destroy a human mind
and i think he probably found out yeah
it can
for example i discovered
documents citing an experiment
in the federal prison in lexington
kentucky
in this experiment seven
african-american inmates
who are segregated and given triple
doses of lsd
every day for 77 days
without being told what was happening to
them or what they were being given
the purpose of that experiment
presumably was to find out if that kind
of an overdose can destroy a human mind
and undoubtedly the answer is
yes you can we never were able to find
out who those people were
the records were just were destroyed and
so i've often wondered
those seven guys did they survive did
they ever
figure out they couldn't have known what
had happened to them
they were trapped in this mk ultra web
so
lsd was used for terrible purposes
under uh sydney gottlieb's
supervision that was not however the
only way that he used lsd
he had an entire other interest and that
was
to find out how ordinary people would
react to
lsd under clinical circumstances
so he decided he wanted to set up
experiments
in normal hospitals uh in which
our research facilities and so what he
did was
he set up a couple of bogus medical
foundations
to disguise the fact that the money was
coming from the cia
and he had these foundations notify
hospitals and university clinics around
the united states
that we this foundation
wants to sponsor and pay for
experiments in this new psychoactive
substance called lsd
and we will supply you with the lsd
you will then advertise in newspapers
for volunteers you will tell them
exactly what it is
what's going to happen to them uh you
will pay them
with money we will give you and all you
have to do is write down
reports on their responses and we pay
you for this
as a result of these overtures almost
overnight a whole new market grew up for
research in lsd
and a number of hospitals began carrying
out these experiments
some of the very first people who
volunteered to come in and try this new
psychoactive drug
were people who went on to become
godfathers of the counterculture
one of the first was ken kesey the
author of one flew over the cuckoo's
nest which was like the first counter
culture
bible uh he took lsd at the menlo park
veterans administration hospital in
california in a
in a an experiment that was sponsored
and paid for by the cia
although he didn't know that and neither
did the hospital they thought it was
paid by some foundation
um ken kesey loved the lsd
he went he went so far as to get a
job in the hospital that's what provided
him with all the material for that book
one flew over the cuckoo's nest but as
he later said that wasn't the reason he
got the job
in the hospital it wasn't because he
wanted to gather material for a book
it was because he wanted to steal the
lsd
and take it home and share it with all
his friends which is what he did
allen ginsberg the radical poet
later great lsd evangelist also got his
first lsd
through one of these experiments in
california so did robert hunter the
lyricist for the grateful dead who
immediately took lsd home and told all
his other grateful dead friends you've
got to go and try this drug
it was through godly that lsd leaked
out of laboratories and into the counter
culture
john lennon was asked about lsd in his
famous
playboy interview and he said we must
always remember to thank the cia
now john lennon had never heard of
sydney godley nobody had
but if he had he would have said we must
always remember
to thank sidney godley so unwittingly
godly became kind of a godfather of the
counterculture and of course the irony
is that the drug
that godly hoped would give the cia
the tool to control the world actually
wound up fueling a generational
rebellion
which was aimed at destroying everything
the cia stands for
wow wow um
now did a lot of people talk about
with drugs psychedelics specifically um
like uh psilocybin mushrooms or lsd
there's a thing that happens called ego
death um was he aware of that and was
that kind of what he was
aiming for when you talk about
destroying someone's mind destroying
their ego
i think that godly was more interested
in the effect of
massive doses he was i don't think he
was interested so much in using it for
psychic exploration he did that for
himself he later said he used lsd at
least 200 times
and i'm sure he was also a psychic
voyager
but that's not that wasn't his
professional interest he was not
interested in using it as a way to
increase people's understanding of life
for themselves
he was interested in using it as a tool
for covert action
and he was trying to find out if it
could be a way to destroy a mind so that
another kind of psychic suggestion could
be inserted
later he finally concluded that it was
as he put it too unpredictable
you couldn't tell how lsd is going to
uh affect a particular person in a
particular situation
some might become very talkative and
tell you what you want to hear others
become very defiant
they have just the opposite reaction so
ultimately he found that lsd was not
reliable for this purpose
but uh self-experimentation was
definitely one of his principles
and i'll tell you something that
happened to me uh
in uh right after this book was
published and i was
being questioned about it uh i had
suggested
i had wondered in my own mind this
question godly came up with such
bizarre totally sick if you want to look
at them from
an outside perspective ideas for
experiments how do you combine
various forms of torture all at once to
see if they can destroy a person
is it possible that he could have
conceived
some of these experiments while he was
actually
tripping on acid himself and when i
suggested this
somebody even offered us another step
forward that i had never even thought of
which is godly was traveling around the
world to observe these experiments
including people
experiments in which people were
experimented to death
do you think he could have been on acid
while he's actually
watching the experiments unfold
who knows wow
now so did he ever did he ever find any
sort of success did he ever successfully
destroy somebody's mind
i'm sure he destroyed many minds and he
killed many people um
we have plenty of cases in which the
person was
reduced back practically to a vegetable
state i talk about one woman in canada
who
went in because she had postpartum
depression she went in for counseling
with a psychologist
she was seized and placed into one of
the basically pulled into the web of the
mk
ultra madness and she was for the rest
of her life
unable to recognize her relatives or
hold a fork
her mind was uh successfully destroyed
we have no idea how many people this
happened to
but uh the number must be quite
substantial
the paperback edition of my book has
just come out and i
i added an afterword at the end and one
of the things i say is that since the
hardcover came out one year ago
i've been getting emails from people
saying
i i've been spending the last 50 years
trying to find out what happened to me
well i think i was caught up i i believe
i was an mk ultra victim now that i put
the pieces together and i see
who was where what was going on i think
it was me that's what destroyed my life
how can i find out
and all i can say is you can't but there
are a lot of
poignant stories out there and uh
at one point sydney godley in a piece of
them secret testimony said something
like uh
i want the members of this committee to
know that i found this work very
difficult
it was challenging wasn't what i'd like
to do but it was very important
so when he said it was very difficult
that's what he's referring to it was
very difficult that i
i had to supervise all that so um he
must have put himself
into a mindset where he was able to
justify
you